Have you ever achieved something that you felt as though you didn't really deserve?
Like being voted MVP on your sports team,
or winning an award for an artist I made you did.
Or even something as simple as getting a good grade.
In the moment, you are ecstatic and overjoyed,
but as time went on you began to think.
"Did I really deserve this?"
You become suspicious of everything,
thinking maybe it was a joke and you're the only one that's missing out on it.
Or you become so paranoid that you hide behind a mask,
in fear of someone realizing that you were indeed a fraud?
If so, this is a common phenomenon known as the Impostor Effect,
and that you're not alone in this feeling.
Far too many of us have similar experiences to this,
whether at school, at work, on the field, in the orchestra, etc.
We're here to let you know this phenomenon,
so that you may be able to recognize it, and overlook it in the future.
In 1978,
two psychologists, Suzanne Imes, PhD
and Pauline Rose Clance, PhD
observed this trait among high-achieving women,
who questioned their intelligence,
and thus were unable to accept their success.
According to Clance and Imes,
there are four behaviors that start the snowball effect of the Impostor Syndrome.
Preventing belief in one's own abilities and accomplishments.
One. The first behavior involves diligence and hard work.
Although these are common traits of any persevering individual,
the person suffering from the Impostor Syndrome
works tirelessly out of fear that they would be discovered as a fraud.
So they try to catch up to the intellect they think people view them as,
never getting there.
Thus, a vicious cycle begins with fear of being discovered as a faker,
leads to overworking,
and hard work leading to temporary approval from superiors,
which the person is subject to not believe.
And it repeats all over again.
Two.
The second behavior focuses on having a sense of phoniness.
This is whats meant by saying they wear a mask.
They don't talk about their true feelings or ideas,
rather saying what they believe their superiors or classmates want to hear,
or expect them to say.
The person who is suffering from the syndrome
will support another person's ideas, and downplay their own abilities.
This allows the impostor to believe that no one can critique them,
or dislike them,
because they're so supportive and agreeable.
Three. The third behavior involves
using charm and perceptiveness to gain favor of their superiors.
The impostor wants to be recognized by their professors
or coaches as a star pupil.
So they tie that mask on tighter and try to win over their hearts.
This person wants to gain the support and reassureance
of their abilities from the superior,
in hopes that it will help her gain her confidence in her own abilities
beneath the mask.
Unfortunately, after the impostor recieves their validation,
she may begin to question her abilities,
thinking the validation was given because of her charm and good acting skills,
and not her intellect.
Thus, a vicious cycle of seeking reassurance from different superiors
leaves the impostor unsure of her own abilities
and talents.
Four. The fourth behavior is the impostor
avoiding to display confidence.
Modesty is the best policy
is a true ________ for an impostor.
If the person suffering from the syndrome avoids showing confidence,
no one can challenge them on their intellect or ideas,
because they never go out of their way to announce them.
Avoiding conflict and confrontation is key in this situation,
because the impostor fears that if they
show any bit of confidence in their ideas or abilities,
her peers will fight her on them,
and shun her for her ignorance.
After all this, do you feel like you
relate to the traits of the impostor in question?
If so, then you've experienced the Impostor Syndrome as well.
You might be wondering this pressing question,
"Can this be treated?"
Thankfully, the answer is yes.
According to Clance and Imes, a “multi-modal therapy
in which several therapeutic approaches are used concurrently
seems most effective in altering the impostor belief in a client.”
as well as “a group therapy setting or an inter-actional group
in which there are some other high achieving women
experiencing the impostor phenomenon is highly recommended.”
The group setting is extremely valuable because
one, women feel more secure when they realize
that they are not alone in dealing with the impostor phenomenon,
and two,
women have a chance to reflect when they her another woman’s story
and the lack of reality in their rationale.
This can even be broken down in this video.
From watching this and hearing about the effect,
and relating it to yourself,
you begin to realize that you are not alone in these feelings,
and others around you experience the same thoughts.
By recognizing this impostor
as feelings, and pushing them aside,
you can no longer be afraid of being exposed as a fake.
You can be confident that you're not one.
What do you think about the Impostor Effect?
Let us know in the comments below!
If you like this video,
be sure to check out our other social media for more content.
And don't forget to subscribe!
Thanks for watching!